jury selection continues in the upcoming
murder trial of derrick shovin
he's the former minneapolis police
officer accused of killing george floyd
in custody
last year on friday the judge rejected a
defense request to delay
or move the trial but as omar
villafranca reports
he is allowing evidence that shows
floyd's arrest in 2019.
keep your hands where i could see him
the may 2019
body cam video shows george floyd in a
previous encounter with
different minneapolis police officers
police say floyd swallowed pills during
the traffic stop and was later arrested
[Applause]
cbs news legal expert rikki kleeman says
the ruling
favors derek chavin's defense the whole
theory
of defense in this case is that george
floyd's physical condition and the
ingestion of drugs
is what caused his death and derrick
chovin did not
but the judge denied the defense's
request to delay and move the trial out
of minneapolis as far as change of venue
i do not think that that would give the
defendant any kind of a fair trial
beyond what we are doing here today
last week the city of minneapolis agreed
to pay the floyd family
27 million dollars to settle the civil
case
two jurors already chosen for the
criminal trial were excused after they
told the judge
the civil settlement would make it hard
for them to stay unbiased
i think it will be hard to be impartial
all right
13 racially diverse jurors have been
selected so far
with one alternate remaining they start
hearing evidence at the end of the month
for cbs this morning saturday omar
villafranca
dallas